what we did was we noticed this was
awkward because 17 is a jerk okay it's
not a nice power of anything except
further except for 17 okay so so how can
we do this now we did some sort of fancy
daisy around with our moms and you may
or may not have kept up with it and
we're gonna revisit this problem I want
you to recall that our second line last
that's working right right there's one
was we tried this and we're like oh I'll
do with that but then we did our our our
dancing around our manipulation and our
second last item IQ is this pretty sure
okay now we got this we didn't just get
it directly right we had to do that
maybe I don't know three or four line
it's everyone in between here but we
noticed hold on
like look at this and this line I think
the really really similar okay
is this something we could take
advantage of here okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to take this idea and
I'm going to formalize it for you this
is a I'm going to give you a law and you
lot more you don't have to memorize this
log law you can just go through the
process that I showed you before okay
but it's so useful and it will be
something that you be into next year for
sure that you might as well encounter it
now because it comes out of these
questions so this law is called the
change of baseball and it's called bat
very originally because what we try to
do is see this log it's got a reader
looking base there right five I can't
work with that okay but if I can change
that base to something I can work with
more easily then I'm sweet and my
calculator can take care of it yeah
sorry say again
do do what oh we did solve it last we
have another flex right here Oh in case
show you oh yeah Johnny go ahead give it
up it's two point something right yeah
one point something one point yeah good
yeah because do you remember right we
knew it was going to be what we wanted
to we knew it's between what it see
because they remember think about your
intuition because good so five is like
over here 25 is over here and seven
teams somewhere in between so that's why
we got this and it's like cool since
check it makes sense okay but now I want
to I don't want to be more than just a
sense check I want to get the exact date
so I wanna get it every time all you
guys straight from one line to the next
okay so here's what I'm gonna introduce
to you we're going to say let this equal
this now this this looks really hard cuz
like I don't know what it means I don't
know it is I know it is but that's
powerful when you don't know what a
number is the number can be anything so
what I'm going to prove to you is a
result that will always work not just
one that like sometimes work for these
particular numbers okay so now if I've
written this as a LeMat equation how
could I rewrite this same equation in
exponential form like with indices yeah
Kamath
fantastic all right so if you recall
right the easiest part to write first is
the bases right
this base is going to become this pace
and then you think well okay and like
the whole definition of knowledge is how
long how much time is it going to take
me to grow to this and usually that
belongs up in the index okay so a the
power of for that amount of time is
going to be equal to B that's really
good okay so now I'm going to pull this
trick if you remember the way we the
lines we had in between he was I said
let's let's take logs of both sides do
you remember I said that take walks so
I'm going to say the left-hand side and
right-hand side I'm going to write this
okay
now let me make a quick note again if
you have your calculator there this
would be really useful when you reach
for your calculator No and that's
exactly I'm gonna talk about I'll you'll
notice I haven't put any base on either
of these signs
okay I'm gonna make cm for Betty I'm
just gonna make a bit of an explanation
as to why okay the first reason why is
because as I progress through this
mostly the mathematics doesn't care
about what base it is I just like these
numbers like who knows what M is or a or
B they can be anything and that's why
this is so powerful this will work all
the time no matter what nothing in place
there so that's the first reason I
haven't put it into there but secondly
and I just wanna explain in more detail
on your calculator right you'll see you
have a mod button okay and when you do
it when you press log it um it looks
just like this right it's doing this
kind of thing okay now the thing is that
log button even though it doesn't say
sir it has a specific base attached to
it and the specific base is 10 okay now
why is it 10 the way you can know it is
if you have a look just above the one
button it says this
okay so you've got that indicator there
saying oh there's a 10 right above it
I think this button has something to do
with 10 and the reason why they chosen
10 is because again I live do this
quickly these are scientific calculators
these are calculators that scientists
use like that's not just an accidental
main and the kind of numbers that
scientists the most interest in using ah
not a minister do we're surprise
surprise scientific notation which is
all about based head okay because you
know our counting system is base 10 now
as it happens like this is really weird
it's a scientific tool it's a scientific
calculator but mathematically base 10 is
actually not a very interesting base to
choose right it's really nice for
writing scientific papers and that kind
of thing but all the interesting
mathematics you will encounter mix here
has to do with a completely different
base not log base 10 of some number but
log base now this is read unusual number
which I'm knocking out time to introduce
to you that today I'm going to tell you
what it is it's a number which I'm it
goes on forever but it's approximately
2.71828 okay and we think about this
number and how long something growing is
that rate alternative is okay this
number is really special it's so special
it gets given a name it's called eight
right it's it's really special and so
therefore this log is called the log
natural right it's the natural log it's
um
remember this is all about things
they're growing this is this is for some
reason just like circles I have to do
with pyrite that number everything that
grows in an exponential way he frets
potential Carosi this way so so called
the natural log and you will find the Ln
body right next to the log button okay
it's on it's another kind of one and you
could use that for this as well okay but
that's something which you make more on
in more detail next year I just want you
to know that it exists
you can once I show you this you can
change the base to anything you like
okay so let's finish it shall we
I'm very close by the way when you have
a look at this line that I've written
okay just coming back to this proof now
get your head back into the space of
your calculators what can I do this is
there anything obvious that jumps out
you just simplify but left on the right
hand side I'm power right this em up
there it's just kinda like why is he up
there like what story came out the front
okay so I'm gonna put the end there
unless we block a and long B we care of
that all right now the whole point was I
want to take this thing oops use me and
I want to rephrase it in terms of like a
nicer base not like some random number
line
okay so therefore here if I divide both
sides by log a okay then I'll have M
equals log B on log hey and by
definition like what I started with that
means this log base a of B equals this
thing on the right hand side and it's
log is base is anything I like it can be
base 10 it can be basis three in two
point seven one number it can be faced
by giving me the base 52 I don't care
right it'll work for everything in fact
I actually want you to try this out
quickly now remember we did this okay
five to power of something equals 17
okay and we got this number out by using
this in our calculators just to show you
that it's going to work with any number
instead of punching in log 17 log 5 that
button there I want you to go over to
the one just to the right this one right
which is another law but they just
choose any different bets so it's gonna
end up looking your calculator just my
walk something like this
if you do as a fraction anyway you can
do the division so it doesn't matter
okay now when you hit equals
assuming you have it in put everything
correctly sure you get one point seven
six again and if your calculator could
do log base two of seventeen and log
base 2 of five
you're still getting your point seven
six so you can get any number you like
it here in fact the full statement of
this the change of baseball that's it
right there
it introduces another letter it
introduces an extra base in there which
they need to say that B can be anything
you want like you can make C just like a
and B any number that you choose and it
still works which is very very powerful